he was on hand to cover Bachelor alumni
Jade and Tanner's wedding it'll air on
ABC Valentine's Day and current bachelor
Ben Higgins was in attendance I caught
up with him about his own ladies
specifically the controversial Olivia
who fell for Ben fast in this whole
process he's mine
Ben and I have the strongest
relationship Olivia was eliminated this
week and Ben did defend her you are in a
relationship I mean on that first night
if I think I'm offering a rose on that
first evening it's kind of saying yeah
well let's start this relationship no
matter how it looks or how long it lasts
on that first night we're starting
something and I think the best were to
describe it is a relationship but with
all those bachelor folks on hand
was there any awkwardness at these
nuptials Chris soules is here today
Becca was on his season she's on yours
as well have you guys had a conversation
about that is that a little strange at
all we have that kind of stuff you're
gonna date multiple people sometimes in
the same I guess ring or you know then
they same friend group well Valentine's
Day is coming out what are Ben Higgins
is Valentine's Day plans Valentine's
planning
I'll probably be watching the special on
ABC 8:00 7:00 central
sounds like a low-key evening will you
be watching alone